so
my friends big nights big nights
triple eviction uh gino you know the
first house guest evicted not knowing
that it was a triple how are you feeling
right now sitting here with summer and
marty
uh obviously i was a bit upset the way i
left um you know the incident why i
found myself on the block uh i feel like
that was still in a house especially the
calm that happened for the last hoh i
think i had it in the bag to be honest
on the trivia king i won two already um
but it is what it is i'm here um it is a
situation but
the experience was great and i'm i'm
still happy at the end of the day
uh summer marty you guys have had some
time to reflect
on the events as they transpired how are
you feeling today about what what went
down
um well i'm still a little hurt um
because it was joshua for me in that
position
but i will say carlos you're my guy i'm
watching you if i'm feeling good why tv
yes
well i feel good i was down but now i'm
now i am up because of you so thank you
i'm glad i'm glad we do a little
something marty
how you feeling
uh it was a tough night honestly like i
didn't see it coming i thought josh was
going out the door like toledo which was
my final two told me like kevin told him
already he was putting him out and
so
i
as much as it was tough to go through
like as a big brother fan like you know
like i really love like these are great
players and they play with me so it is
what it is
but like gino said like
overall like i'm taking like it's still
like a great experience i'm glad i had a
chance to experience this is
everything's good
yeah marty on your way out of the house
uh you made it clear that your vote is
not decided at this moment you know
it'll go to whoever plays the best game
so
if you had to vote for a winner today
who do you think that you'd be voting
for who do you think is playing the best
game
if i were to vote today i would vote for
kevin
um
even if they didn't win a whole lot of
count con like just the way that he
played the game like i was mentioning
that earlier but like whenever gino was
hoh and he did that andrew bit when he
was the lawyer and went there like he
was so good that we
played the game and like that alliance
he had with josh like i didn't see it
coming and played me so like right today
i would vote for kevin but there's still
a whole lot to be played uh and like
like arisa said last night before the
calm fun fact none of you ever won a hoh
like it's it's there's still a lot to be
played at this point but today i would
vote for kevin
gino
gummy bears man
the fate of your game came down to gummy
bears like do you
will you ever be able to eat a gummy
bear ever again
no actually it's it's uh it's
dramatizing obviously my hands was in
the hands of a gummy bear uh that's the
reason why i'm here but i did tell them
when i get a tattoo of gummy bear right
on my fingers would be a red glowing
burst i'm always remember that moment
but yeah it kind of sucks it was that
the way i left the house i haven't had a
feeling that i was going to leave once i
hit that block
but it is what it is and i'm going to
live with it
uh summer when you left the house you
know you didn't hug or say goodbye to
anyone you said you felt betrayed
talk to me about that um what was the
biggest one biggest betrayal
uh well
i did actually hug betty two times uh so
i hug one person got that out of the way
um and i would say the ultimate betrayal
was from joshua he placed me in that
position and then he actively worked to
make sure that i didn't stay um so yeah
it was joshua everyone else i didn't
really
care i just had a feeling that they
weren't on my side anyways to begin with
so yeah joshua
betrayal backstab broke my heart a
little bit but
is he my friend no so it's all good
uh the three headed dragon gino on your
exit out of the house she said there's a
three-headed dragon in the house who
were you referring to and why do you
feel that way
so
hermsey called it out um i kind of saw
it that's how i felt the game was going
on
it was marty helena and kevin uh i saw
him being his number ones for a little
while so i felt um like they were the
three-eyed dragon
but the way it flipped when i walked on
i kind of told myself like wait this
makes sense because marty uh was trying
to push him to save me he got played as
well so i got played because of a flip
but before that that's the strong
feeling i had it was m3 working strong
together
so for all of you what is your strategy
now uh going into jury will you still be
playing the game or do you plan on
i mean do you plan on letting your guard
down you got to play the game right
me oh um
so i'm still playing the game that's for
sure i'm obviously less stressed more
relaxed because that house has drove me
nuts to be honest
um but at the end of the day i want to
make a logical decision i don't want to
make an emotional decision i want to see
the best clearing the finals and i don't
want to
base my decision on what they did in the
past i want to base my decision on how
they got there and why they got there
summer what about you um
carlos i won't even lie to you i am an
emotional person and i'm very petty so
um
i don't know how long this is going to
stay but i do plan to come down from
this high and hopefully well i know i'll
make a logical decision but at the
moment it's like josh you can miss me
with that phone um but maybe later down
the road if he does if he does make it
that far and he can answer my question
then he may have my vote but yes i do
still plan to play the game to some
degree and make a logical decision at
the end
marty what about you
i'm a big brother fan i wanna i want the
best person possible to represent season
season ten i don't care if somebody
backs at me or like betrayed me in the
past if i judge that
they had the best game overall at the
end that's the person i'm going for
and for all of you again who is the next
person that you want to see
walking through the jury house doors
let's see josh walk out of there
carlos you know the answer joshua come
on
i i think that josh has a better chance
of winning so actually if you would walk
walk in i'd be very surprised and i
think the only way that's going to
happen is if
chase lee wins that if she does
she she'll take a step towards my vote
yeah do you know what's what's going to
happen with jc lynn outside of the house
now
you know that question was coming um
obviously we talked about it we talked
about it in the house uh it was a great
experience with her she was my she kept
me sane she was my rock
i obviously built a lot of deep
relationship
in connection with her so we did
consider taking it out of the house
we're gonna give it a try and see how it
works uh being in the house and out of
the house is two different worlds so but
going through all these emotional
rollercoasters in the house i feel it's
the like it would benefit us in real
life and probably be easier so i was
going to give it a try and see if it
works out but i'm open to it
yeah yeah yeah i said earlier on that
you had some time to reflect but
obviously things still feel pretty fresh
if you could sum up your experience
in big brother canada
right now what would it be do you know
let's start with you
a lifetime unique experience that i'm
never going to experience ever in my
life i was an emotional roller coaster a
lot of ups and downs good and bad days
and it's something i'm always going to
remember that's for sure
um i would say that it's been a blessing
and um it was the ultimate test to my
spirit and
all in all it has made me realize that
one there's a lot of internal work to do
that'd be real but at the same time i'm
stronger than i think so overall a
blessing
i'd say it was a an incredible journey
like i'm so glad i got a chance to
experience that honestly i think i grew
up the person when i was in the house
and
the last thing i'd say was like toughest
thing i ever did in my life by far
yeah yeah all lessons learned um
bittersweet but it is good to see the
three of you
and uh thank you so much for the time
looking forward to seeing what happens
next